♪ [music] ♪
Give me one minute and I'll show you
how Cloud Pub/Sub can help you
keep your services
reliably communicating with each other.
Cloud Pub/Sub is an asynchronous
messaging service,
which means it helps your tools send,
receive, and filter events or data steams.
It gives you durable message storage,
scalable in-order message delivery,
consistently high availability
and performance at any scale.
And Pub/Sub runs in any Google Cloud
region in the world
so you can easily use it in Jakarta,
Frankfort, or Montreal.
And of course, everywhere else.
You also don't have to provision Pub/Sub.
It scales global data delivery
auto-magically.
From zero to millions
of messages per second.
With Pub/Sub, data producers
don't need to change anything
when the consumers of their data change.
Just publish once
and let us manage distribution.
This let's more of your services
be entirely stateless.
You set up Pub/Sub between services
or applications by defining topics
and then subscriptions,
which allow services
to receive the messages
published on those topics.
This means one-to-many communications
gets much simpler.
So you can spread batch image analysis
over multiple workers
or send logs from your security system
to archiving, processing,
and analytic services.
Or, if you got a steady stream of data,
you can use Pub/Sub
to steam that data into BigQuery
or Dataflow for intelligent processing.
Pub/Sub is really handy for notification
when something bad happens,
so you can page the right teams
if a system or service goes down.
So, next time you need a way
to connect multiple services,
applications, or data sources,
take a minute to try out Cloud Pub/Sub.
Learn more at cloud.google.com/pubsub
♪ [music] ♪